The Joe Rogan experience. I was broken. I was coming up, man. Let me just start.
Huh? Where'd you start doing standup? Back in Detroit. In Detroit? Yeah. I was,
um, my brother used to go to acting class on Thursday and his wife, I said,
well that's pretty cool. I should try to be an actor.
So I got in the yellow pages, they had them yellow page.
They don't have now though.
Everybody got to go through the phone and get the number,
but they had the yellow pages. I go, I went the yellow pages.
I went to an acting class, private acting lessons, and I had called the guy,
he said, $25 an hour. Come on over. I'm done. We can get started.
So this teacher had John [inaudible] acting classes could in a comedy show once
once a year and you say, I want you to be on the show. I said,
I don't want him about no comedy. He said, well you,
this was very lucrative business. You can make a lot of money. I said,
we really,
I one that stole the show. Why is it, wait a minute.
That's funny. The oldest I used to do impressions of Nike and Cole,
Johnny Mathis and uh, wasn't boy Joe Cocker and all that stuff.
Oh, Mick Jagger. I used to Mick Jagger. Jeez, don't go eat,
go, go.
And they had about 500 people out there for the show.
I'm bouncing across the stage like Joe Cocker. Boy. It was so funny.
And I got a standing ovation and I said, wait,
am I could probably make some money doing this.
I really was money money was your number one motivation when you broke money is,
you know, tell them I love it. Yeah. Fiction. That's some bull.
I didn't have it at my wish. I didn't have that luxury. No luxury.
Get out of my wish. I can count this.
Where did you start out in LA. What clubs did you start out here? Oh,
I drove from here, joy to LA. I moved to New York. I moved to New York. Um,
six 71. 1971. That was about 30 years old. 29 30.
And then I went to material can be a fashion model. I was fashion mom,
Detroit fashion commercials.
I worked at Cadillac motorcar and,
and my job was plating bumpers, deep Dick fucking bumpers.
And so the bumpers, I would need the monies,
I'm picking this up cause you know you use now, you used it in journalism. I,
you losing endorphins and everything else you got in your body to kick in and
put this big bump on this fucking line.
Do it to keep going and get into the plating pit.
So I have now the bumper going down and I had about three minutes,
I looked at his magazine, I saw that gas man next to a car.
So I look better than that dude. Damn. I went into the,
I went to the yellow pages again and got me a call.
The acting lady called the M Marlene schools. They said, Oh sure, come on in.
They gave me a job that weekend. I thought I was hot there.
I went to New York and I'm do look 10 times better than me
as you a model. See you.
I'm the midget model. So I couldn't do that. So I,
I uh, I got the hell out of there. I went back to the, you had went to New York.
I went new state,
New York three years back to LA and I met but I did Detroit and got a car and
drove in de LA by myself. And when you went to LA you went to do stand up? Yeah,
I went to the [inaudible] and I'll stand up. Stand, cut that Molly.
Now cause I have never said that shit at work. Where did you uh,
start out doing stand up here at the comedy store store? Yeah,
that was the first one that I was there with Mitzi. Wow.
I was there when Mitzi first started.
Sam had to please Sam and Mitzi breaking up. Mitzi.
Sammy used to send me when on the rules. Sammy was, he was a big time,
calm and keep working for swings are not true. And Dean Martin,
all he opening for them, Mitzi needed somebody.
I needed a place. So I'm, I got a job. Mission gave me a job as the MC left.
Dave Letterman was EMC. The first shot I MC the second show.
He didn't have no money then either. He had a wife,
he had a red truck and a dog named Bob. That's the only thing.
He came to LA with me. I just had this blue. I had this blue Whoa Mustang.
I bought about 150 to drive to LA,
a hunting $50 car drill tail all the way to LA. Wow. You know,
I was determined to get out there and get me some of that money.
Leaked all the transmission fluid.
I had to get out every 200 miles to fill the car back up with all and
transmission fluid every 200 miles on a mouse. I bet that night man,
Oh, Oh. You hear this shit and it's donating only light.
You see headlights on the car. I've got at that point got, I'm going to stick.
I had to stick with me and put your head little funnel.
Put that all in that car looking around. You know I'll be doing, yeah.
Uh huh. And got to California. No, I actually went to the Las Vegas person.
I'm fucked. You got stuck. I got stuck in LA. He told me about that.
What happened? That blew his money.
I had a guy tell me to keep this thing in front of you. Can you grab that? Oh,
here. Yeah. Tell me my friend, he rich boy.
He said, look, just go to go to Las Vegas per se with the comics are doing.
Then you go to LA di, you know what they're doing and they get,
that's the comics. They work in Las Vegas all the time. I went there,
the old ass joke, Jewish joke. They planned to tell it and, but gay Kaplan,
this old, funny big head look. Ain't funny. He's a good actor,
but he, he was, I waste all my time.
He told me stay there half an hour. I mean halfway half of 30 days, stay there.
So I paid up my rent for 30 days and I went that night I met my new man Navy
suit on him and shot up his, I can beat boy Marlene close. You know what I mean?
Standing around, you know, had a big old Afro man.
I lost every dime I had at that fucking horseshoe casino. I was,
I went back home crying. So
now I don't know what the hell I'm gonna do here. I didn't,
I drove two and a half days across the country and so I,
I called people in Detroit, try get some money, but you know when you call them,
you don't always wait. Hey, nobody got no money. People don't answer the phone.
They say, Oh no, I ain't got no money.
So I got some more borrow money from some of my friends in the state.
Had to stay there for six months till I got no money to go to LA.
Well you said that then you tell me that you hit,
you did one of the slot machines in it. It hit with Adoree grant.
I had $150 left. I saw Donna Rose. See what I would do,
I would go at night and during the weekend,
during the weekend mean you can go to the front of the uh,
casinos and the guy in the front day say, I'm a comic.
I just want to sit in the back here and watch some the comic and I'm gone. They,
they let you do that. Just sit there and wait to anybody.
Nobody's sitting there. They've got 2000 seats in little places,
something like that. So I had a dollar and a half left. I saw down. And Ross,
he had a great show. So on the outlay, I said,
I'm gonna play this fucking money. I just just be broke.
My check is coming from the unemployment. Uh, it'd be here another day or two.
I can go without food for a day.
Most of them. I said, burglar, you better put some down here, n****r. Yes.
So I put that money in the machine. It rung up,
I think it was 7,000 rarely. Yeah. I thought I fucked up something.
Oh shit. Now what have I done? The guy came, well, he said, I just got on jobs.
Just hold on, sir. I just got here.
You had struck the jackpot today. Hustle jackpot.
I, he gay. He came and just put them $100 in my hand. It was like a miracle.
Even like, like Moses came down to hand me some money or something.
They was so damn, that money felt so good. I went home
and pack my stuff. I had about two more days on my rent.
I got in that car, I got me some gas, Joe,
you know how they have in Vegas?
They got the little Island in the middle of the street,
drove over that damn thing, going back, going the opposite direction. I said,
hell with this. I'm, and when you go Island Casa, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, cones come out and does come out. Old cones, old stuff.
Come on old on that seat on your hand, your feet be dirty,
dusty, all nobody.
I drove all the way from three o'clock in the morning,
four o'clock in the morning, wherever the timing was.
I drove all the way back to LA. Um,
and my friend let me stay at her house for about a month. Candy.
She was good friend of mom, dad. She let me do that cause that was,
that was amazing. She lives in Beverly Hills from crumble from apartment,
motel. I mean, uh,
no money eating potato the worst.
I so now I know what time me to get some money. I'm eating a baked potato,
um, a white potato now
with the white potato and some old bread as some syrup.
And I say, I gotta get the fuck outta here. This ain't, this ain't no,
this is not good for the kid.
I come out here with big plans and I went straight.
I went straight to her house and I got a job at Gucci and I went to the comedy
store and everything. I just stayed there. If you didn't go to Vegas,
would you have even gotten stuck? I wouldn't have gotten stuff.
So that's a six month.
That's a six month waiting game that you had to play because you lost some money
on it.
It's worse counting airplanes coming in and taken off cause you can see them
from my, my door. You see the plane and come into the Karen,
I think the name of the hotel at the video, the plane terminal.
They come in, you see them take off. That's all I did all day long. He playing,
coming in as wild plane, taking off, playing, coming in, playing,
dig it off and you're just stuck. They're stuck in Las Vegas.
I learned I deserved my moneys.
So people are telling you your love money? Yes,
I deserve every dime I went through today.
That shits. Oh my God.
That car lasted for another four or five years.
Really fit 65 Mustang. That's a great car.
It is a great car. Regular gas. I gotta get some new tires.
I told you I gotta be some new tires, a case of oil and a case,
and I got a,
I never forgot I got my old color TV and a bucket of Kentucky fried chicken
back then. When you trying to get up in the store, how did,
how did the auditions go? What did they do? No, you don't have to.
You have to go through the a potluck. You had to go through that. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. Hoping Mike the same today. But it wasn't that many comments.
Hit the close at about 11 o'clock. I didn't know comics that go on anymore.
How many comics were there? Oh, he must've been about 10 15 really? Huh?
What years is 74 so it was at the beginning. As soon as we,
soon as Mitzi, Mitzi just started, I was there in the beginning. She, she,
she liked me. She get me, she, Johnny come out here and work the door.
You can do anything you want. I said, I need a job. Mitzi.
So I hustled a door. Mitzi. She said, y'all better watch it Johnny.
He can make some money at that damn door. What I would do, I was,
what'd he call him? Maitre D or somebody call him maitre D.
so I will put a reserved signs in the front seats up there.
Reserved for the owners, grandmother, Missouri, further mothers grant,
mrs father. And so none of the main movement,
I mean the main room and the other room be crowded, packed people. I said,
we sold out sir. He said, what did the tables up there for? I said,
that's two owners. Grandmother be here soon.
He's with $500 or put me in that seat right now.
So I would make, I would make,
I would make it two to 300 a night sometime 500,000 just at the door,
but the Mitzi, then she had me go MC and all that stuff. Well, you said
$500,500. It wasn't that kind of money. That's a, that pictures her.
That's Mitzi. I know. I recognized that pigeon. Eh,
that's when she was younger though. Yeah.
There's a photo that was from the comedy store that was sitting around the back
room and Taylor boss. That's when I, he passed it. Yeah. That's when I, um,
I, that's what I knew her when she was like that. She was, she's a,
that's the picture right there. That's the picture he used. She was, Oh,
smart lady. She was, let me tell you some brother. She was a whip.
She was, she had her ways. Yeah, she was,
she was definitely Accenture.
But she's one of the most important people ever in comedy and comedy.
And people don't realize that. A lot of people don't realize it.
Mitzi was the shits.
She and that little Pauline is crazy and running around. They little baby.
I know, I know Pippin, Polly says in the baby,
I know I'm all Mitzi. Mitzi him. Johnny ain't gotta come back.
We don't have nobody to work the door. I can get up and go over there.
So I met the door, I got eight o'clock show. You don't eat a clock.
So I mean I'm seeing and working the door and everything and,
and hosting the room and all that. So I'm up there on stage. Um, put the new,
got a little broke you put across the door and close the curtain.
And if you know people come up in the original room to come up the steps there,
you know the original room. Sure. So she's in the booth taking money,
taking pictures, taking money and get selling tickets.
She and I are the only one there working and, and the bar in the back.
So, uh, Mitzi, I'm going to stay by buh buh buh buh buh buh buh [inaudible].
Got 10 people in the room. So go sheets. I'm just go here and I get them.
I get there, give me the cover and you go ahead, put the rolled back.
So now I'm up to about, I got 15 minutes. Oh shit.
She say about three minutes, four minutes into my and Johnny.
There are people that in line come down here and let them in.
You cannot do your more. No more material. Come on Johnny. That's a Mitzi.
I'm trying to finish my ag. Johnny, come on. I want to get this money.
That's I learned never commercial like get did money before they turned around
and go, Oh God I, that was a funny,
she sees the funniest lady. She's the funniest lady. Let me tell you.
She was hot. She was tough. Mitzi was tough. She told me, you stick with me.
I make you a rich man. I said, miss, I come here to be a comic.
I can to be no bitch, man. I'm going to be a comic, but she's too much trouble.
Too much accent. You like saying centric two weeks injury.
I didn't want to hang around too long. August. Still there out of his mind. See,
he's still there. Aren't you still in there? He was there last night. Yeah,
I know. I go there and see him. I see him all the time when they,
when I go back down, I want to go once a year or so. But I see our guard.
I like August season. He was townies. Talented. Yes. Genius. But he didn't,
he didn't want to lead a comic store. Mm. He got a radio station downstairs.
He told me they have a podcast. What's a podcast though?
They have a podcast studio. [inaudible] studio. Yeah.
But Mitsi Ivanhoe and Mitzi. Mitzi.
I knew her in 1974 when I went over there and I noticed when I got on,
when I got on, um,
open Mike night for people who wanted to try to become on the regular show.
Mitzi used to love impressionists. She loved people who could do voices.
And I just realized that after about three weeks of being there,
trying to be funny as shit, I'm doing old red Fox jokes. I'm doing a,
but I hadn't been that the horse race was gone and,
and the jockey, you w we ran on my Dick.
The horse name was Maddick fucking red Fox used to be,
he would come by and he would be so fucking funny. Um,
so at the end the person come out and sing.
She loved people that saying Tina Turner women, this 18 attorney,
she put two or three of them right behind each other.
They still want the same song. Jesus, that's a MySequel and crazy boy.
[inaudible] impressionist. But since y'all love the women,
go do you know the women?
All of them got the same impressions but she put the two or three of 'em on the
same show. Wow. Same impressions. I went up there,
I started doing impression down there cause I did amend Detroit on the shoulder
with the Nike and Colton, him, she's all Johnny, this is so wonderful.
I want you to work Friday night. And she put me on early.
He put me on some nice times and shit. But,
but she wanted me to stay with her on that door and emceeing help her out.
She had me click closed the door closed the place. One day I just miss,
I shouldn't be responsible for this. Tell you came to close the doors,
lock the fucking door. Well, she's always had comics work there all the time.
Getting all the time when I wanted to, where I wanted to work though.
Most of them comics live in their house upstairs up there and crest Hill. Yeah.
Yeah. They lived in the, on the Hill there.
She bought all the property around there. Yeah.
Mitzi own myths on so much show on some with money when she died. Oh my God.
The house up on this house. The house that you know,
the house she had up on the Hill there. Crest Hill. Yeah.
That's what the name of the house on the street.
That was the one where all the young comics lived in it, right? No, no, no, no.
Dodd common lived behind the comments to up the Hill is you get about three to
$4. Yeah. She owned about three or four.
I went over there to have a party over there. The fucking party was fabulous.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm looking at California and he had got the house all dirty. You know,
they'd see what and tried to make the bed covers thrown on top of the bed,
you know, just throwing, nothing tucked in. Nothing. Mitzi on all that.
That guy been there. Yeah. I almost bought that crustal house. Yo,
that was for sale back in the day. I went to look at it, but I had a dog.
I was pretty sure he's not. Who's going to get out of that backyard?
I had a crazy dog. I was like, this is not good.
You just the one right behind the store. Right. I think Paul Ali have it.
I think Callie's get the one that's up into the right.
He's got one that the driveway. He owns it, I think. Yeah, I saw him.
I saw him the other night at the, at the store in the parking lot and he was,
he was telling me like how you use a watch and I'm like, God, I newness
watches as I watch him run to the wall and stuff. But
babysitting Kinison used to babysit them too. That's crazy.
I can't imagine leaving your fucking child with Kinnison. Oh yeah, Kevin.
Somebody I told David, let him, and as he said, spoon,
anybody knew what the commies stowed. As a real funny, as a man,
you gotta see this crazy dude named Sam Kennison. And so he said, well,
have them, um,
have them send me the tape or something or give us a call on the show. I said,
Dave, you going to love him, man. Salmon on that show. And Dave judge,
it fell on the floor. Sam was so funny and Sam,
Sammy as a salmon, David and let him, I want to see you on his show. He said,
Oh really? [inaudible] it's first time you ever got on TV. Wow. And, uh,
he was always, he always been my friend Sam.
Sam Kennedy always was my friend cause I used to work Mitzi, uh,
after a while she would get these young cast of like David Letterman to be the
emcee of the first show. So I would work at the 12 o'clock show.
All the crazy people only show me Paul Mooney,
Sam Kinison of all, what's the boy name?
He talked make me eight. Do Elvis. And he did, uh, Andy Kaufman.
Andy Kaufman. I remember introducing him.
I introduced all of them eating my name.
Yeah. No,
just say they come to me and tell me what they want me to,
I didn't want me to introduce them, you know? Yes. She ain't can come and
I'm looking to do like at least fucking man. And Andy, can you
let me show you. You ever see our crazy lending crazy lady with the window?
With the pigs? Yeah. He used to bring dolls on the stage and punched him.
Oh wow. Yeah. He had a, he had a beige dude about like, uh,
like remember the only, the, the bear smoky, the bear.
Only you could prevent it for him. He would pull out the bear.
Only you could prevent four sizes.
Fuck you punch the para who is so meticulous.
And if people, people would come down just to see them, he would go nuts.
And he was like really crazy expressions.
Just an unbelievably funny guy. Like a naturally funny guy.
He was an East coast legend.
[inaudible].